years ago before we started to recycle
all of our household rubbish would have
been landfill now only the rubbish
collected in black bins from houses in
teen bridge is sent to the local
landfill site which is located on the
outskirts of King's faintin this
landfill site covers an area of 200
acres and has been operating since 1980
each year approximately 320 thousand
tons of rubbish is delivered to the site
from all across Devon to take for
example in 2007 2008 teamriche district
council sent twenty two thousand five
hundred tonnes of waste to landfill
that's enough to fill 2200 of our large
refuse trucks
I'm stood on the tipping face that he
filled landfills light waste is brought
here across seven not just team bridge
and as you can see it's a really really
busy site
these days landfill sites have really
well managed and this particular around
me you can see that there aren't any
scavenging Birds let's take a look at
why hello my name's rich and I'm a bird
controller here at needful landfill site
and with me I have t's who is a
peregrine falcon crossed with a Lanner
Falcon it's our responsibility here to
stop the scavenging Birds from coming to
the tip in order to feed on all of the
rubbish is disposed of in this area
because of all the different types of
rubbish that at disposal an alarm call
site
fortunately attracts all of the wild
scavenging birds which are looks throws
most of the corvid family we have Jack
dogs here and lots of seagulls and in
order to stop those birds from picking
up pieces of food and taking them into
the local environment into the towns and
the cities we use birds of prayers and
natural deterrent in
in addition to the birds of prey we also
use other devices such as kites ripped
ropes and rockets in order to create
enough of bird disturbance to the local
birds to keep them away from the site we
also use various different species of
bird depending on what species of animal
that we want to a deter from feeding
here one of the main problems with
sending our waste to landfill is that
methane gas is produced when
biodegradable or organic material such
as food and garden waste are buried
underground methane is a harmful
greenhouse gas that contributes to
climate change at he field landfill
sites the methane gas is piped out of
the ground and is used to generate
enough electricity to power 7,000 homes
however not all the gas generated on the
site can be captured and the production
of methane at landfill sites is best
avoided regardless of whether it can be
captured and burned to reduce the amount
of biodegradable waste that we send to
landfill and slow down methane release
into the atmosphere residents are asked
to please separate their food and garden
waste by putting it into their green
composting bin so where does all of our
green bin waste go behind me you can see
an in-vessel composter and this was
built at heath field in 2004
it is here that the green waste for
green bins is taken and turned into a
valuable soil improver this facility can
process 25,000 tonnes of biodegradable
waste each year and compostable waste
for both team Bridget's our parents
district council mr. lived here every
day
each year team which deliver over 17,000
tons of green bin waste to the in vessel
composting facility that's 17,000 tons
of green waste that would have been sent
to landfill once the green waste has
been delivered to the site it is put
through a giant shredder it is then
loaded into large concrete Bay's where
it is left to heat up naturally the
green waste has to reach temperatures of
over 60 degrees centigrade for 48 hours
to make sure that any bacteria such as
eco light are killed this can take up to
a week to achieve the compost is then
transferred into another large concrete
Bay where it must reach 60 degrees
centigrade for a further 48 hours after
the compost has heated sufficiently for
the second time it is taken outside
where it is regularly turned to allow
air to circulate through it it is then
left to mature for up to six months
before the compost is sold to local
farmers it's a scent for a huge sipping
machine so that any unwanted pieces of
plastic or textiles can be removed